now am I about to put my career on the
line is the question you know they get
me because you want me to get rid of you
because you're the real person hi
everyone my name is Jack Wallace and I'm
a dialect coach here in Los Angeles
today we're gonna try and figure out who
has a real American accent and who is
faking it one of the things that can
happen when you're doing an accent is
that it's terrifying and so I've got to
be lucky helpful kind of who seems a
little nervous and he'll throw anything
out by my questions if I had to make a
wild guess I'd be down to two out of
five right now hi my name is Teddy and
this is my natural accent hi my name is
Elise and this is my natural accent hi
my name is Nadia and this is my natural
accent hi my name is Rachel and this is
my natural accent hi my name is Blake
and this is my natural accent what are
the things that happens when we talk in
an accent that isn't our own is that we
kind of have this impostor syndrome
feeling and then some people might just
not like to be on camera so can you tell
me about your favorite subject in school
it would have to be history just being
able to kind of backtrack timing and how
it all led to present time hey there at
least sounds good good could you tell me
about your hometown this is it LA mm-hmm
excellent what do you like most about LA
the people here are really weird hey
Maddie
hi can you please tell me about your
hometown yeah I'm from Iowa Cedar Falls
small small town
thanks and what's the best thing about
Iowa the Sun sets
all right hi there how's it going good
can you tell me about your favorite
subject in school I would say math
because I like to add great yeah do you
have a favorite thing that you add
together 1 & 2
what's it get 3 you should do math more
often thank you I like that one can you
please tell me about your hometown I'm
from a little town in Texas called for
sure less than one thousand people so
good old Teddy here he seems pretty calm
pretty relaxed it feels like when he
talks
it's the way he would normally talk at
the moment I think he's in the clear now
at least it's very hesitant to talk
almost like she has to plan what she's
about to say but when she does speak it
seems to have American features the
jury's still out on at least now he was
also one of the people that was quite
nervous when she came in but then when
she was telling me about Iowa is a very
specific place to choose so either
that's a good strategy or she's actually
from there
Rachel Rachel this math very confident
which go against all the things that
I've said I'm looking out for and then
lake on the end if you're gonna go for
an American accent sometimes people go
to the South first because they're like
oh I couldn't disguise this better am I
about to put my career on the line is
the question I would get rid of the men
I would say
Nadia's an enigma to me right now
if I were to get rid of one of the
people I I would like to get rid of
Nadia but I think she's taking a good
game because you want me to get rid of
you because you're the real person you
sure yeah okay we're gonna eliminate
Nadia so right now I'm trying to think
of a word that would trip up somebody
that was not American and because I'm
British I'm already gonna say it
differently from how an American would
say it the words that I would like these
people to say are gonna be Horror Story
Horror Story Horror Story excellent I
would hedge my bet that it might be no
I'm American
yeah I'm actually Australian haha she
was the most reluctant to speak but also
before you say and let the letter are in
American it changes the way you say the
vowel before it but that doesn't happen
in British and Australian accents we
would say ha ha but there are clings on
to it in American it becomes [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah with a little less earlier yep I'm
never gonna be able to speak in an
American accent that was so cool this
was really great experiment I think she
did a great job making the sounds but
there are just a couple of little
nuances that she can work on in order to
convince other people
you
[Music]
[Music]